north and south korea have both tested
ballistic missiles within hours of each
other on wednesday south korea announced
it had carried out its first
submarine-launched ballistic missile
test just hours earlier north korea had
launched two of its own ballistic
missiles that landed in waters between
the korean peninsula and japan it was
the second missile test by the north in
five days and a violation of u.n
resolutions japanese prime minister
yoshihide suga had this to say about the
launch
it threatens the peace and security of
our country and the region
and is outrageous
we will hold an emergency national
security committee meeting later today
we will work closely with the united
states south korea and other related
countries and will firmly protect
people's lives and peaceful livelihoods
that is all from me
the missile launches on wednesday came
as chinese foreign minister wang yi was
in south korea meeting president moon
jae-in prior to their meeting moon had
in fact witnessed the test of the
submarine launched missile
carried out by his country both china
and south korea are party to the
so-called six-party talks format to
bring about denuclearization and peace
on the korean peninsula a commitment
that was repeated at the wangi moon
jae-in meeting
of course we all want to contribute to
the peace and stability of the korean
peninsula
for example
not only north korea but also other
countries are conducting military
actions
so we should have all the parties make
joint efforts to resume dialogues
we will make efforts to denuclearize the
korean peninsula and establish peace we
hope for china's unwavering support and
hope that minister wang yi will continue
to play a big role in supporting our
government's efforts to develop south
korea-china relations and denuclearize
and establish peace on the korean
peninsula
join me now from seoul is jungmin kim
she's a correspondent with nknews.org a
website focusing exclusively on stories
from north korea chiang mai i'd like to
talk about south korea's missile launch
first a submarine-launched missile is a
significant military capability for any
country to have
what are south korea's motivations here
i think i can refer to what south korean
president moon jae-in said earlier this
year he said
power leads to peace and i think it is
one of the main motives when he thinks
of military capabilities in south korea
which the country has been boosting a
lot this year and slbm is
the latest news of it the intention here
would be like the president put it
himself just now he says it would work
as a great deterrence capability against
north korea
we know that north korea also developed
submarine launched ballistic missiles
and although south korea does not have
nuclear warheads
it seems that they are using it for
like president moons that deterrence uh
capacities for south korea and the south
korean missile launch of course came
just hours after north korea itself
fired two ballistic missiles
are we seeing a new arms race on the
korean peninsula
oh definitely we are seeing
something like a competition going on
between the two countries on which
high-tech weapons they are developing
and showing off on state media and in
south korea's case through press
releases and videos and photographs
it seems
that the missile test today on south
korea's end was already planned but it
was definitely an interesting
coincidence that it just came hours
after north korea tested their
short-range ballistic missiles
and also just a few days ago there was a
long-range cruise missile test by
by north korean military and today south
korea also released information about
how they tested cruise missiles as well
now where does that leave talk of peace
and denuclearization on the peninsula
and it's something that chinese foreign
minister wang yi and south korean
president moon jae-in also spoke of in
their meeting earlier today
it was interesting
thinking from that perspective as well
because uh the south korean president
moon jae-in
and chinese foreign minister wang yi
talked about how um they wanted the 2022
beijing olympics to be something like a
platform for the inter-korean
cooperation and dialogue will be bloomed
again although north korea is
technically banned from the olympics by
the ioc now um from north korea's point
of view it seems that they're saying
they don't really need these symbolic
peace sounding uh projects or
initiatives or humanitarian assistance
like the u.s president a u.s
representative to north korea kim has
put yesterday but they it seems that
with these ballistic missile tests and
other types of weapons testing north
korea seems to be reiterating that what
they really want are the serious stuff
like the security guarantee that they
want from other countries
what kind of a security guarantee
exactly does north korea want
to put it simply if they want to they
have been
pushing for this idea that if other
countries especially the united states
want north korea to
denuclearize or get into
denuclearization talks uh these
countries with good capacity to uh
tackle north korea and um tackle north
korea will have to
somehow
persuade north korea that other
countries won't be targeting north korea
with their military assets
and in terms of these guarantees is it
looking at but a potential permanent
stop to joint u.s south korea military
exercises would that be a first step
that north korea is looking for
um i think so it would be part of it and
it would be a big step from north
korea's point of view it's not only
about security guarant guarantee but it
also stands for something symbolic like
the u.s forces in south korea
not making quote-unquote hostile moves
or hostile policies targeting north
korea and doing more practices near
north korea
and north korean high-level north korean
officials including north korean leader
kim jong-un's sister kim yo-jong has
made it pretty clear in recent
statements that they really want these
drills to stop but from the allies point
of view
these are drills a business as usual and
they need this to guarantee their
readiness posture now north korea is
also facing food shortages and a
worsening economic situation primarily
due to the covet 19 pandemic the
question therefore would be why focus so
much on missile testing and security
guarantees when north korean citizens
are suffering
to the north korean leadership it seems
uh that they they are trying to tone it
down a little bit although they are
doing these missile tests they put they
did not put that on the front page of
rodon shimon with the latest one and
they put it on the second page and kim
jong-un wasn't there so definitely the
focus right now is on domestic issues
like solving the food crisis and
everything but uh testing these missiles
also
does like uh
the internal propaganda
functions well because they are
stressing that the country is trying
very hard to keep the country's people
secure and safe from the outside hostile
forces or the enemies so
they are
sort of going for both but to me it does
seem like the despite the recent missile
tests the focus is indeed the domestic
issues like the economic problems
jungman came from
nknews.org always a pleasure talking to
you thank you so much for joining us
today
thank you for having me